[Applause]
out in front in the race for number 10
now with a new high profile backer Tory
MP Tom tugan hats was standing to be
prime minister two weeks ago but he now
says he's backing Liz truss
one eye on a government job maybe but
campaigning at a London Airfield today
the former Soldier and critic of Boris
Johnson says he understands why the
foreign secretary and others stayed
loyal I can see why people like Ben
Wallace and Liz truss stayed in the
cabinet my views on the Lost
Administration have never been a secret
I've been completely open about it since
the beginning but those who decided to
serve had a responsibility to serve and
I can safely say that many of them did
meanwhile at a Cotswolds estate party
prep for Boris and Carrie Johnson's
wedding celebration the event delayed by
covid is reportedly happening this
weekend at the home of a Tori donor
it's another day of fun for the outgoing
PM a fortnight ago he was flying fighter
jets in Lincolnshire before holding a
leaving party at his Countryside Retreat
and visiting Ukrainian troops training
in Yorkshire
with the leadership contest too it's led
to accusations of a government and prime
minister missing in action on the big
issues facing the public not so says Liz
truss he's done a fantastic job in
standing up to Putin in delivering
brexit and in delivering our vaccine to
covid and helping us deal with that
great crisis I think he's entitled to
enjoy his wedding day and I wish the
best to him and Carrie and all the
family
with Westminster empty of MPS for summer
the focus is now on Grassroots
supporters around the country we aren't
even halfway through this leadership
race yet but the coming days will be
crucial that's because ballot papers
start landing on Tory doorsteps from
Monday and many members are expected to
vote in the first half of August at the
moment Liz truss appears to be running
away with this contest leaving Rishi
sunak in desperate need of a game
changer
that didn't arrive last night but there
weren't any disasters either as the
former Chancellor faced a TV grilling
over his opposition to immediate
widespread tax cuts it would be the
easiest thing in the world for me to sit
here and say no I don't want to do any
of these difficult things I'd like to
give everybody all these nice things
don't you think that would make my life
easier it's because I genuinely believe
it would not be the responsible thing to
do that I'm saying that we should go
down this course be careful with our
borrowing manage it carefully but help
people with the cost of living this year
Liz truss said today the contest was
still very very close that may be
underselling her lead but with five
weeks to go there's still ample time for
slip ups and breakdowns Rob pal Sky News
in Westminster